they are my hot dates my parents are the
hot date is that what you do so you're
safe and so we won't ask the question
you know there's there's always a little
bit of a buzz around my dating life so I
try to you know my parents are my dad's
house yeah how's that sound well that
sounds good but there is a buzz around
your dating life Harrison yes
interesting a little who bass I will
tell you yeah who I think is the smoking
hot like she's the smoke in his hot
hottest if that is a word person that
I've ever seen Sharna Burgess is there
anything there's she she is a babe so
hot oh my god it's shocking are you
confirming that there's a little
something there I mean I have a crush on
her for sure I don't know if we're
dating have you gone out on a date maybe
who knows okay
when you what we're just gonna put in
here when you win a Daytime Emmy yeah
will she be in the top three people that
you call definitely and I thought yeah
she is she's the most confident woman
that I know and I will love and here's
the thing she's like a down-to-earth
chick who is I mean everything the total
package Oh completely I wish I wish we
were dating
you
[Music]